millions of americans are re-evaluating
their careers and our next guest is
ready to help elaine walter roth former
editor-in-chief of teen vogue knows a
thing or two about reinventing her
career she was the youngest
editor-in-chief in the conde nast
magazine history when she got that job
she has also been a co-host on the cbs
show the talk she wrote for the popular
tv show grownish published the new york
times best-selling book and now she is a
judge on the hit bravo tv show project
runway oh yeah she does a lot her own
master class draws on all of these
experiences to help others design their
own unique career paths she also offers
key tips on how to maintain a work-life
balance take a look
when i left my corporate job
i made a pact with myself because i knew
i didn't want to build a company that i
didn't want to work for
so
while i said yes more than i said no
i told myself we are only saying yes
to projects when you can find
it in you
to say hell yes
hell yes this is exactly how i want to
be spending my time this is paying more
than my bills this is giving me a sense
of value in those spaces that i want to
be hell yes we got elaine welcome right
now good morning how are you doing good
morning hell yes to be honest
i would say hell yes or no i love you
when i got this phone call i said a big
hell yes wow well thank you for joining
us um let's talk about your own personal
experience and how all of these things
your paths have taken you here to
creating this master class well you know
i think i'm a part of a new generation
of creative entrepreneurials who don't
necessarily look at their career as a
singular path and i know coming up i
wish i had more
examples or more of a blueprint of how
to navigate career transitions and think
about a long-term career that is going
to be
multi-faceted and and and dynamic and
really more than one thing and i think
when we ask kids what they want to be
when they grow up
it sort of puts them in a box like they
have to have one answer there's going to
be one job title that's going to define
them forever and what we know about the
job market these days is that's just
unlikely yeah and the days of working at
the same company and doing the same
thing for a long period of time and
being miserable and it are long gone
that's the thing you talk about elaine
zone of genius what is the zone of
genius i love this concept
i do i so the concept of zoning of
genius i'll say there's a lot of people
who
might be too afraid to take a bet on
themselves and i understand that fear
and i think the best way to push
yourself out of fear paralysis is to
make a plan
and i think your plan should be informed
by your zone of genius and i define your
zone of genius as sort of that sweet
spot or intersection between your you
have it up there your passions your
values your skills and your talents it's
that thing that no one does quite like
you so we're at this interesting time in
the u.s economy where four million
people a month for three months straight
have walked away from their jobs right
yeah go into something new
that's a scary thing for people some
people are on the fence may not do it
what advice do you have for those people
who are have yet to jump but are
thinking about it they're not they're
not happy and for those people who've
now jumped
yeah i mean congratulations to those who
have jumped um it is a scary thing to do
to start over i'm sure all of you guys
have experienced certain career
transitions they are scary
and like i said for those who are
sort of on the edge and just need a
little help this master class is really
for you it's designed for you whether
you're just getting into the job market
as a you know college graduate or your
mid-career and you're making a pivot or
you're like my mom who just retired
after 43 years in the same job and has a
whole life left you know like this is
the time to really dig deep do the
excavation to figure out what motivates
you what do you care about more than
money those are your values and those
should be driving what you're how you're
spending your time since you referenced
us i feel like we got a case study over
here in nate burleson and how to make
career changes boldly former nfl player
uh then you did some local hits in
detroit on television then you were
working for x extra yeah now you're
working for us you know all about this
you could give the master class on no no
well i love you what do you say when you
talk about picking lanes and that's
perfect segue tony because
when i was younger i think we all
experienced it what do you want to be
when you grow up that's usually singular
you get to high school you know what do
you want to study in college and you're
done with college what job do you want
to all these things right and you say
pick your lanes and in the illustration
there's 14 fill in the blanks yes which
means you can do multiple things you can
wear multiple hats because you you don't
know how something fits until you try it
on that's right and why do you think
that's important for everybody to know
you don't have to pick one lane
by the way i left out jobs in that
little summary of what you do
all aboard
he's a graphic designer yeah yeah
there's a lot of double devils
just the shoulders off a little bit so
you're you are the consummate
multi-hyphenate and i think you
represent sort of a new definition of
success for a new generation of of
people entering the job market they want
to
figure out what they're good at which
sometimes takes some exploration and
then they want to have the freedom and
flexibility to try new things and to
build a career that is fulfilling first
and foremost um and to fail if you if
because i feel like people don't want to
fail that's right you're going to stub
your toe occasionally and that's okay
and and you're going to get your dream
job and guess what yeah you don't have
to dream of another one
right so i always say you get to the
mountain and there's another one that's
right another one
your life is a series of dreams realized
we're right you're running out of time i
don't want you to go without people
saying without people noticing you have
a baby on the way talk about i think
that's a dream congratulations thank you
once you were nervous about being a mom
you got that glow girl oh thank you
thank you so nervous oh yeah i'm nervous
this was not part of the plan let me
tell you at this stage but um but i'm
i'm i'm pivoting yeah powerfully and i'm
i'm present in what's happening in my
body and i feel grateful for this moment
um
and i'm i'm i'm excited about the
journey ahead of being a mom
looking like a spring baby spring babies
are the best yeah it's going to be a
swimming pool i need some tips from
motherhood tips from you gail i'm
excited i'm excited i don't think you
need any tips i think you got this but i
also want those boots
all right i can hook you up looking at
your boots going who's damn i like those
elaine congratulations on all your
success thank you clearly clearly
continue to soar continue thank you so
much gail